well a lot of people may not know this
that you are the co-creator of the
wonderful between two ferns that's well
yeah have you heard are you down with
TPP uh I'm not down with TPP no you're
supposed to say yeah you know me like
the hip hop group don't tell me what to
say well you recently had the episode
with Hillary Clinton how did that come
to fruition well the campaign reached
out to us and said that they really
wanted to do it said that it was
Hillary's idea we don't know whether
that's true or not that's what we were
told and so is it came about really
easily I really regret doing this we
didn't know what to expect but she
walked in she was very game she gave us
more time than she had agreed to stay
there a while I think she was gonna give
us 35 minutes and we just kept rolling
and she gave us over an hour oh well and
you know and then we found out later
after the fact that that was the day she
had been diagnosed with pneumonia and
she got there two hours late because she
was doing a CNN interview that she had
extended for a really long time too so
she was just working very very hard and
yeah it was it was a really great
experience would you ever have Donald
Trump on the show no Zach said I think
we had a lot of carpeting week we got no
way yeah I don't think there's anything
funny about him unfortunately it's very
scary
you